turning to asia now north korea is
telling its citizens to show greater
loyalty to dictator kim jong-un 10 years
after he took control of the
nuclear-armed country the grandson of
north korea's founder remains in office
in spite of signs the country's economy
and people are suffering elizabeth
palmer is across the dmz in seoul south
korea watching the anniversary of kim's
rise to power
as kim jong-un walked with the car
carrying the coffin of his father north
korea's former dictator kim jong-il
the displays of public grief would have
reminded him he had big shoes to fill
but a decade on he's done it
these unforgettable pictures released in
2019 show a man in charge not only of
his horse but of his country
ryuhanwu was a senior north korean
diplomat who defected two years ago
how solid is kim jong-un's grip on power
kim jonny he has absolute power ryu told
me that's how he maintains the
dictatorship kim jong-un as
commander-in-chief of the armed forces
has amped up north korea's weapons
program
on his watch the country has tested four
nuclear warheads
and in 2017 a missile capable of
reaching the united states my friend his
meetings with president trump in 2018
and 2019 failed to kick-start
negotiations on denuclearization
in return for sanctions relief
and at the party congress earlier this
year kim jong-un reiterated the us
remains north korea's biggest enemy
but kim's other enemy is the pandemic
he's sealed the country's borders
against it which means no trade and no
aid even donations of vaccine
they won't even receive the china the
chinese sinovac or one of the chinese
vaccines
apart from a lack of syringes says
there's no reliable electricity to keep
the vaccines
grand military spectacles mask north
korea's suffering
no one knows how badly coveted has hit
but reliable reports say people this
winter are going hungry
ten years in power have left kim jong-un
isolated in one of the poorest countries
on earth and armed to the teeth but no
closer to getting what he really wants
and that is relief from un and u.s
sanctions
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer seoul